I imagine this film to be international
for sure which means bigger budget
unfortunately but yeah it kind of has to
be this is a global topic it's a global
issue and yeah I don't see any way
around having to travel all over the
place i'm looking at possibly you know
eight to ten cities with throughout the
united states asia and europe at this
point yeah and that's that I'm still
researching to do you envision how long
the pre-production process will be an
actual shooting little post thank you
yeah the pre-production phase because
I'm so in it now and kind of doing a lot
of the development working already we
kind of have a good head start and all
the pre-production work but yeah I think
I need about three four months to do
proper pre-production and plan the
production phase properly yeah so your
vision maybe it will take a couple years
to have it totally finished
unfortunately yeah um yeah I'm picturing
about two years for this film yeah which
is pretty good considering how long
documentary can sometimes take and when
did you haven't forgiven if you've
already said this but what did you have
the first idea about this was this when
you're still doing the source or woman
what did it kind of strike you because
you know they'll be that like idea hmm
this interesting is if you kind of like
Rooney yeah think about it you remember
when did it happen um yeah so yeah I saw
the movie into great silence back in two
thousand six but I still hadn't come up
with an idea to do a documentary but I
was more just kind of personally
interested in silence and then I read an
article about John Cage and then got
really excited about silence again this
is like years later after watching into
great silence and then I started hanged
spending some time with Nathaniel door
ski this experimental filmmaker who we
actually hired to consult on the source
during the post-production phase on the
side he does like editing consulting and
he's done editing consulting for POV and
bunch of major documentaries and so I
had the honor and privilege to work with
him and just kind of get to know him and
pick his brain and then I started seeing
his work and turned out he was this
famous like you know experimental
filmmaker and I just loved this idea of
like of making a film that's of
something you know rather than about
something and and I think that's when it
all came full circle was like integrate
sounds John Cage and then Nathaniel door
ski this is how I can actually execute
this film and it was kind of a
no-brainer at that point yeah so taint
your question more directly it was
probably within the last year so that
came I came upon it yeah and you
mentioned before that you can become
obsessive sometimes about different
things like Kickstarter whatever did
that become your new obsession is like
oh and then your mind starts finding
things that are of silence for a noise
total yeah yeah and yeah silence it
definitely could become an obsession of
mine a healthy obsession i hope but it
has to be if you're going to spend two
years of your life minimum on film you
have to be obsessed with the topic or
you're just you're going to be miserable
it's likely going to be challenging and
kind of miserable at times anyway and so
it better be something you cared dearly
about you know so yeah I'm glad that I'm
obsessive about it and that's kind of
how I knew it was time to make a film
about it yeah or most of the times when
it's painful and miserable are those in
post uh yeah the pain and misery is just
kind of a reoccurring thing throughout
the production of a film I feel like I
mean there's there's challenges along
the way in every phase of the production
post production is definitely one of the
more challenging phases I think of
making a project and
let me think about that for a second um
yeah I mean there's pain and misery
throughout the whole thing you know it's
it's hard there's a lot of blood sweat
and tears that go into making a phone
but that's what makes it great and so
rewarding at the end when you do finish
you know especially if documented you
just don't know what's happening you
don't you really have to be on your toes
the entire way because the story is
developing and unfolding before your
eyes and it could go a million different
directions you could tell the story in a
million different ways and it's yeah
it's it requires a lot of you for sure
yeah and financing alone is probably one
of the key you know sources of pain and
misery in any given independent film
you